just like you asking me to have sex in
the school at her table right now give
me class please I was 18 years old it
was the end of my senior year of high
school I had this friend Dylan and I'd
been out of the closet as gay for two
years and he knew that and he was of
course totally respectful and supportive
you know we talked about girls together
and bond over that and I had never been
with a guy before and I don't even know
if I hadn't had sex with a girl at that
point or being completely naked with
another person ever so one day we were
just kind of talking about it and he was
like well if you ever want to you know
who to call he was joking though you
know it wasn't one of those like lesbian
hunting like straight dude type of
things it wasn't like that at all
I was just sitting in my room like
thinking about it and I was just kind of
like you know I think this is something
that I want to experience before I go
away to college
Dylan was the first guy that I thought
of and I texted him one day would you
maybe want to like actually try doing
that sometime and I don't know it took
him a while to respond and I was like oh
god he was really sweet about it he said
like I don't want to disrespect you as a
gay woman are you sure about this but
I've thought about it a lot and I was
already so comfortable with him I wasn't
worried about it being awkward we're on
board
what plan I was just really nervous to
do it at my house I don't want to do it
in like a car like that's - like grungy
I'm not gonna I don't want to do it in a
car so I was in rehearsal one day for
the last play of my senior year Dylan
was the sound guy for all the school
productions and he had texted me one day
you know this is kind of like crazy and
weird but I have the auditorium free for
the next two hours which was on the
other side of campus and I was just kind
of like and what are you implying you
didn't have any sort of idea
I did I was just like are you asking me
to have sex in the school auditorium
right now I had some time to kill
I guess and I had done all my homework
and I walked across the school campus
and my heart was pounding so hard I was
so nervous just watching to this like
huge School Auditorium
nobody's there and I look in the back
and there's Dylan sitting in the little
sound box and he just kind of waves to
me so I didn't know where this was gonna
take place I was like I mean we're not
gonna do it like an auditorium Cheerilee
and he was like you like cool to climb a
ladder right now like open this door
with just this huge ladder and like 5060
feet and I was just like Dylan and he
was like it'll be fine like we can
there's like space up there so I start
climbing and climbing and climbing and
climbing and I was nervous too as my
hands are sweaty and was of course
obviously afraid of falling and then
when we got to the top it was really
dark he laid the blanket down and we
just sat facing each other and he was
just like I'm afraid to kiss you I was
just like that's okay like I'm afraid to
have sex with you and we'd like held
each other's hands
and just like leaned forward and started
kissing and he was a really good kisser
surprisingly
clothes start coming off and it was
really really hot up there like we were
both covered in sweat and he has the
condom and he was just like are you
afraid of it hurting or anything I was
like yeah I am it actually didn't hurt
which I was really nervous about it
hurting I didn't really know like what I
was feeling at first I guess it was just
so weird and different
a feeling that you never felt before in
your entire life after like 40 seconds
of kind of getting used to it I was like
this feels pretty good actually
I'm pretty relaxed and then he stopped
and I was like you can keep going and he
was like I finished after like a minute
after all that build-up it was just kind
of like sort of anticlimactic I guess
nobody had ever made me finish at that
point in my life anyways so I didn't
necessarily like expect to but I
definitely wish that it would have
lasted a little longer and I could have
like taken more time to enjoy myself I
guess afterwards we just got our clothes
back on and we got back to the drama
room gave me a really big hug and we
just kind of looked at each other he was
just like you're still one of my best
friends nothing changed afterwards it
was never weird
full disclosure Dylan and I like a few
years later like slept together and it
was still really quick and I guess at
that point I was like okay I'm not gonna
do that anymore you know you like look
at yourself and like look at the facts
and you're a lesbian
you've never slept with a girl you've
slept with this guy that can be kind of
confusing you know regardless of how
sure you feel like it doesn't really add
up and the first time I slept with a
girl all those doubts and everything
just kind of went out the window once it
wasn't awkward and quick and it was fun
and awesome I kind of had the
realization like okay like you don't
need to feel that way anymore this is
what sex is supposed to be for you as a
person it doesn't mean that you're not a
lesbian we're humans and I think that we
should be allowed to explore what being
human
[Music]